homeland security bill is ratified after
eight years British borders will remain
closed the deportation of illegal
immigrants will continue good morning
our lead story the world was stunned
today by the death of Diego Ricardo the
youngest person on the planet baby Diego
was stabbed outside a bar in Buenos
Aires look there we are the first shot
of Alfonso Cuaron's children of men is a
shot of an audience getting information
about the state of things in the same
way that we do through the media you may
have missed it but Cuaron's fundamental
motif of contrasting foreground and
background has already been established
through the media before this shot even
begins let's back up a good morning
story like everyone else the media
prioritizes information based on its
values so much attention is paid to the
foreground to the lead story that the
background can go by without much notice
the lead story of children of men is the
story of Theo in a future world nearing
its end because women have lost the
ability to have children
Theo an apathetic government bureaucrat
returns to his roots as a political
activist after he sees that there is
still hope left for Humanity the film
plays as an exciting action thriller as
Leo helps the pregnant ki get to safety
with the human project but as the plot
moves along its linear path following
Theo the camera repeatedly becomes
preoccupied with what's going on in the
background and this is a technique that
chlorin has used in the past and it
makes for an interesting effect as in
thousands of other films we experience
the world through the eyes of the main
character this process of identification
is automatic and strong so strong that
we can even be made to sympathise with
people who we would otherwise identify
as bad or evil so when the camera
actively breaks that identification and
shows us imagery the lead character
doesn't see
notice were made forcefully aware in a
purely visual way of the perspective of
the film itself in children of men that
perspective is absorbed by the
background by a bleak gray winter
Britain the only country in the world
still under stable government control
this background seen always at a
sidelong angle probes and investigates
the conditions of that stability whether
or not it's worth
what's sacrificed to have it though it's
dressed up with a few futuristic
flourishes the world Quran presents to
us is a reflection of our own the grim
combination of nationalistic xenophobic
politics and late capitalist consumerism
isn't something that we have to imagine
when Mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best they're bringing
drugs they're bringing crime they're
rapists in 2006 when this film was made
only five years after 9/11 and at the
height of the war on terror this was and
in many ways still is the state of
things thousands of migrants and
refugees in the war-torn Middle East and
Africa a rude awakening awaits in
countries that are moving to close their
doors and there's another background to
a figurative background of cultural
reference for example when key first
reveals her pregnancy she stands in a
posture reminiscent of Botticelli's
Birth of Venus one of the many
references in this film to Maternity
jasper and miriam both recite and each
we're calling both the pawnee shots and
TS Eliot's the wasteland which is a
major source of inspiration for an
infertile world that's lost its way
outside Theo's cousins arc of Arts a pig
floats above the old Battersea Power
Station an overt reference to Pink
Floyd's album animals a concept album
loosely based on George Orwell's Animal
Farm itself a satirical indictment of
authoritarian socialism or Stalinism
indeed there's a lot included in the arc
of art scene here's a Banksy here's
Michelangelo's David Picasso's Guernica
significantly framing Theo in the
realities of war and underneath it all
plays King Crimson's progressive
rock anthem' to the Court of the Crimson
King blending the sacred and the profane
but Lauren's referencing becomes more
potent as the inter texts layer and
connect take this shot here it utilizes
nearly all the techniques I've mentioned
so far you have the lead story moving
again toward its destination at the sea
but the camera leads them for a moment
to focus on this mother cradling her
dead son
the most immediate citation here is to
Michelangelo's famous sculpture la Pieta
which Nigel mentions earlier in the film
good luck atop smashed up before we got
that and that sculpture Mary holds the
crucified Jesus in her arms questioning
the cruelty of men the image also evokes
Guernica also shown earlier in the film
a much more modern meditation on the
horrors of war and Quran has said in
interviews that the inspiration for this
image came from a photograph out of the
Balkan Wars itself a reference to
Michelangelo's work whereas the arc of
art shows are extracted and placed in an
ivory tower chlorin puts art back on the
ground where it belongs and brings it
alive within a number of contexts
ancient and current and most importantly
as a background for the main story
there's an absurd paradox that sits at
the center of our modern world while
capital itself knows no borders people
and nations struggling to find their
identities have sought repeatedly to
tighten their borders and restrict
people's from crossing them what's more
these refugees are increasingly
displaced by the militaristic meddling
of neoconservative regimes and the
worsening climate a result of the
unchecked expansion of capitalist
enterprises in children of men as in our
own world all of these things are
intimately connected and yet for each of
us individually it's hard to see
anything but the foreground the lead
story that's why the roving curious
preoccupations of quran's camera are
more than just a size by providing a
disinterested break
from identification they achieved
something we just can't in our own lives
they let us see the world bare naked
stripped for a moment of subjectivity
this is the radical political potential
of cinema we can all keep to our main
stories if we want live in our little
worlds but sooner or later the
background is going to come for all
hey everybody thanks for watching I just
got some awesome nerdwriter stickers
delivered that are now available on my
patreon page you can get them by
clicking right in the middle of the
screen right here or in the description
they are two stickers for three dollars
one payment boom you get them set
obviously I hope you continue to pledge
after that they're awesome for laptops
and backpacks and lunch boxes whatever
you put stickers on they're available
now at my patreon page and a patreon is
what keeps the nerd rider alive and
going and the big goal is to get that
patreon to $1,000 per video so thank you
so much for helping me get there and
making this possible this content is for
you guys see you next Wednesday
[Music]